the source of my depression was that I
was not proud of who I was I did not
feel like I was free in a past life I
had a top secret clearance it sounds
only cool to say did that for two years
realized I didn't really enjoy the work
that was when I got really depressed it
was a very hard time in my life at that
point because I felt like I had done
everything that my father had wanted me
to do and it was his approval that I was
seeking and the thing is is like I had
his approval what I realized was I
didn't have my own approval because I
felt like I had made a lot of the
decisions I made up to that point in my
life because of expectations of other
people that I was trying to meet